can I just say something real quick
about fitness and health in general
everybody I appreciate
your emails to me and comments and H
what's the secret how do you stay in
shape of your age but it makes me laugh
when I hear people say what's the secret
hey everybody no secrets you know what
the [__] answers are you know the
answers to the test you can't when you
ask what's the secret you're expecting
me to be like I found the secret you eat
as much as you want and you never
exercise and you sleep 12 hours a day
that's what you want to hear me say
that's not it you know you know what the
[__] secret is the secret is no
secret and but here's what I would say
as somebody who used to train
people stop making yourself feel
bad that you come up with some realistic
expectations between just not even baby
steps just find the expectations between
between what I want to look like what
I'm willing to
sacrifice and what I realistically know
that I will do as a human right right
when people are like when I see people
like I'm you know what starting January
1 I'm gonna I'm going to the gym six
days a week I'm G to do the ice bath I'm
only eating two meals no you're changing
your life too drastically it's never
going to stick that's why I said baby
steps it's just about real real istic
and you're right yeah it's real just
guys realistic and here's the
realistic moderation man M look if you
want the easy one no sugar you know that
no booze you know that and just you
gotta go way lower on the carbs
especially the bad ones the Breads and
all that stuff no sugar none of that
[__] man no soda and go to the gym guys
there no it's no it's no calories in
calories out I know people like baby you
got to calories in calories out and make
sure the calories are good that's it
that's all that's the end healthy
lifestyle healthy diet but be realistic
with yourself what I would say to you
here's the secret you want to know the
real secret stop making promises to
yourself that you break yeah because
every time you break a promise to
yourself subconsciously you're like look
at this piece of [__] right cuz think
about it if if there was a friend of
yours who constantly broke their
promises to you you would not want to
hang out with that person facts that
same goes for when you're making
promises to yourself right so don't
continue to make promises that you know
you're going to break make the promises
to yourself that you know you can keep
and build from there baby steps I think
is probably the right move for most
people oh yeah hey man hey
man oh yeah hey man hey
man